for more on the immigration issue we are
joined by Teresa Cardinal Brown in our
Washington bureau she is the director of
immigration and cross-border policy for
the Bipartisan Policy Center Teresa good
morning
good morning so what do you make of the
prospects for bipartisan accord on the
issue of immigration in the wake of the
president's comments well I think
certainly the the meeting in the White
House has comments but overall the fact
that the White House rejected a
bipartisan compromise proposal from a
bipartisan group of senators has put the
negotiations around immigration reform
package right now in a little bit of
disarray the Republicans have said for a
long time that they need to know exactly
what the White House needs in order to
move forward the fact that the president
said that he would not agree to what was
in that bipartisan proposal means
they're starting and a little bit of new
with the new set of negotiations and
they don't have a lot of time to get it
done Teresa what does it mean to
dreamers and temporary protrek protected
status recipients to have this
immigration battle in limbo well you
know as as the administration announced
the end of the daca program for dreamers
they knew that at that moment they had
an end date on their ability to work in
and stay in the United States without
fear of deportation and as the
announcements of TPS countries have come
out the same for the TPS holders so on a
personal level for them they are
literally in limbo they know that at
some point they will no longer be able
to work legally and their employers will
have to fire them under law the
employers must fire them they will be
subject to deportation again and their
lives in the United States in many cases
for the dreamers their lives have been
here almost their entire lives for TPS
holders many of them have been here for
decades will be uprooted so for them
this is a tie out time of very high
anxiety and and it wears mentioning that
for some of these dreamers they have no
relationship to their quote unquote home
countries exactly exactly if they came
here as small children they are born and
raised here they speak English here they
learned our civics and history in high
school they may or may not have
relatives back in the country that they
are technically
Nationals of you know we we know already
that in some places like in Mexico
they're having kids who were lived in
the United States a long time deported
with parents who don't know enough
Spanish to be educated there so so it
really is about you know whether or not
we accept that these people are simply
American and everything but papers you
wrote in late last year Teresa that a
daca fix in 2018 would to be too late
what did you mean by that well one of
the things to understand the president
said that the daca program would be
terminated as of March 5th but what he
really meant was that as of that date
the the government would not accept any
more applications for renewals and
anybody who whose status expired after
that date would not be able to renew but
right now the government is not
accepting new applications for daca
status is no longer accepting any
renewals so people are losing status
right now even if Congress were to pass
a fix a legislative program today it
will take a while for the administration
to implement that program it may require
any forms fees regulations
they'd have to allocate adjudicators and
resources figure out what the
requirements would be for approval or
disapproval these applications that all
takes time and just adjudicating the
applications even when the daca program
was up and running it could take some
times as long as six months for those
applications to be considered so if
you're a daca individual even if
Congress were to pass it today you may
not be able to get status four six eight
ten months so much at stake here Teresa
Cardinal Brown in Washington thank you
for being with us this morning